berlin kanzleramt zwei tage nach dem
letzten corona gipfel im
bundeskanzleramt tag frau slomka
viele bürger fragen sich wo stehen wir
jetzt eigentlich in dieser pandemie und
viele hoffen natürlich dass wir so den
das schlimmste also die die tiefste
talsohle durchschritten haben aber wenn
man ihnen gestern im bundestag zuhörte
konnte man den eindruck gewinnen sie
fürchten dass uns vielleicht sogar das
schlimmste noch bevorsteht
das hängt jetzt von uns ab das ist das
gute die armen eine schwierige zeit
jetzt hinter uns und sind noch mitten in
ihr aber wir haben in den letzten
dreieinhalb wochen immerhin die
fallzahlen halbiert das heißt wir sind
auf einem arzt der absteigt wo weniger
fälle auftreten und das ist eine gute
nachricht wir können den punkt das sind
die 50 fälle pro 100000 in sieben tagen
bald erreichen wenn wir uns noch an die
kontakt beschränkungen halten ab denen
wir glauben dass die gesundheitsämter
wieder die kontakte nachverfolgen können
und das ist dann der punkt ab dem man
auch über öffnungen wieder nachdenken
kann und das ist ja das was alle wollen
jetzt haben wir die mutation wir wissen
nicht wie sie wirkt deshalb müssen wir
besonders aufmerksam sein
aber es hängt jetzt von uns und klugen
öffnungs schritten ab ob wir ohne eine
groß ausgeprägte dritte welle durch die
pandemie kommen oder ob wir zu
unvorsichtig sind und dann doch
vielleicht wieder steigende fallzahlen
haben was ich vermeiden möchten
sie sprachen von der von der 50 aber
eigentlich ist doch die 35 die neue 50
so haben wir es jetzt kennen gelernt wir
haben zwei zahlen die haben wir übrigens
auch im infektionsschutzgesetz verankert
ab 50 also wenn man die überschreitet da
muss man umfassende schutzmaßnahmen
ergreifen weil man davon ausgehen muss
dass wir in ein exponentielles wachstum
kommen und damit dann auch eines tages
in die überlastung unseres
gesundheitssystems und unterhalb von 50
gibt es noch die 235 das ist sozusagen
eine vorsicht zahl hat der mann schon
erste schutzmassnahmen machen soll oder
im umkehrschluss wenn man sie
unterschreitet darf man wieder an
größere öffnung schritte denken deshalb
haben wir das mit dem einzelhandel
verbunden mit den galerien und den
museen
für die einzelhändler aber ein
ziemlicher schock die hatten eigentlich
gedacht so 50 gab dann wird es wieder
bald aufgehen und jetzt ist es plötzlich
die 35 kann es sein dass dann vielleicht
in zwei drei wochen ist dann doch eher
25 oder zehn sind auch mit verweis auf
mutter ist erst noch mal bei den 50
gehen wir ja schon einen gewagten
schritt die länder vielleicht manchmal
sogar schon vorher nämlich indem wir
wieder wechsel unterricht in der
grundschule machen indem wir kitas
öffnen weil das von so großer bedeutung
ist das sehe ich auch ein und bei den 50
machen wir noch einen weiteren schritt
ich glaube dass wir die 50 zum ersten
märz erreichen können und dann werden
auch die friseure wieder geöffnet und
dann ist das schon eine mehr an
kontakten dass man beobachten muss und
deshalb haben wir uns die 35 dann
genommen für den nächsten schritt
wie geht es dann weiter das ist
natürlich eine berechtigte frage zum
beispiel auf kneipen für im restaurant
außerdem ist ein gar keine rede mehr die
sind ja wirklich komplett doch doch
geschlossen ist auch in unserem papier
die rede ob es für die ist eine
unglaublich harte zeit und deshalb muss
man dann folgendes ins auge fassen für
die nächsten öffnungs schritt nach dem
einzelhandel müssen wir schauen ob der
stabil unter 35 bleiben oder bei 35
bleiben wenn die gesundheitsämter die
kontrolle haben werden die zahlen sogar
runtergehen lassen wir die 35 es kommen
keine neue zahl jetzt dazu und ich lange
zeit sondern solange eine minute muss
ihn auch das erklären
und wenn wir den öffnungszeit geschäfte
gemacht haben und wir haben einen
infektions zyklus also zwei wochen lang
stabil unter 35 dann können wir den
nächsten schritt ins auge fassen und
schon bei den geschäften sagen wer wenn
es landesweit 35 sind kann man in
absprache mit seinen nachbarländern
schon die geschäfte öffnen selbst wenn
noch nicht alle bundesländer das haben
es gibt öffnungs und wir haben dann drei
stränge im grunde noch wir haben die
schulen in den höheren jahrgängen
berufsschulen unis wir haben die
privaten kontakte als zweiten strang wie
viel mit wie viel menschen da hatte ich
mich treffen und wir haben einen dritten
strang das sind im grunde die
kultureinrichtungen kinos theater
gruppen sport und dann auch die
restaurants und eines tages die hotels
und dann müssen wir politisch
entscheiden welche öffnungszeiten aus
welchem strang wollen wir jetzt als
nächste und darüber wenn wir beim
nächsten mal dann auch diskutieren und
so entwickelt sich die öffnungs
strategie und man kann sagen immer wenn
wir stabil bei 35 bleiben 14 tage lang
und der vorherige eröffnungs schritt
nicht zu einem anstieg der fallzahlen
geführt haben dann kann man den nächsten
schritt gehen
es wurde alles sehr erleichtern wenn der
das wichtigste instrument der ganzen
strategie in ihrer strategie in dieser
pandemie von anfang an der impfstoff
empfindlicher zur verfügung stehen würde
und auch schneller zur verfügung stehen
würde bereuen sie es im nachhinein dass
sie das nicht früher zur chefsache
gemacht haben als sie merkten dass die
eu und die einzelnen vertreter dadurch
recht langsam unterwegs waren mit einer
sehr kleinen bord kasse zwei milliarden
3 milliarden das sind wirklich peanuts
wenn man das mit anderen kostenvergleich
hätte man da nicht sagen müssen zum
beispiel in ihrem amtskollegen in
frankreich anderen sagen immer nur wir
können das so nicht laufen lassen die
amerikaner schocken schon im großen stil
die briten kaufen schon alles auf dann
müssen wir jetzt mit richtig viel geld
ran
ich glaube nicht dass es eine frage des
geldes sondern ich glaube dass wir sehen
müssen dass die amerikaner alles was sie
bei sich zu hause produzieren für sich
nehmen und nichts exportieren und der
biontech chef hat ja auch von sich aus
gesagt am anfang sind begrenzte
kapazitäten und die hätten auch mit mehr
geld und früherer beim vertragsabschluss
nicht mehr anders gesagt er hat mehr
angeboten und sich sehr gewundert dass
die seien am anfang unter putin hat
jetzt neue finanzchef sagt der
finanzchef hat mal gesagt für die erste
zeit also ist mehr angeboten worden
immer die frage ist ja hätten wir im
januar 2021 mehr gehabt und ich glaube
dass also haben wir uns ja immer auch
mit der bestellung des impfstoffs
beschäftigt ist ja nicht so dass wir das
darüber nie gesprochen haben der
gesundheitsminister hat mir schon im
august erzählt dass er sich für die
erweiterung des werkes in marburg
einsetzt aber ich will gar nicht drum
herum reden es gibt eine enttäuschung
und vielleicht hat diese enttäuschung
etwas damit zu tun dass ich jetzt
erstmal faszinierend fand das
überhaupt einen impfstoff haben nach
weniger als einem jahr das ist eine
riesenleistung damit konnte man nicht
rechnen
und dann wir nicht ausreichend darauf
hingewiesen haben dass am anfang nicht
für jeden gleich der impfstoff da ist
man hat sehr große zentren gebaut die
erwartung war im märz wäre diese zentren
ausgelastet sein ende märz april da
werden wir mühe haben alles zu verhelfen
aber die ersten wochen sind jetzt knapp
und das haben vielleicht manche menschen
auch anders erwartet wir sehen ja auch
das ist in großbritannien anders geht
also da sind die jetzt schon mit den 70
jährigen fast durch der telefonieren
hausärzte schon ihren patienten
hinterher willst du nicht endlich zum
impfen com haben sehr viel mehr geld
ausgegeben also ist das ist frage des
geldes sein durchschnitt vier euro
durchschnitt großbritannien und usa an
aufgaben 28 27 euro also geld regiert
doch auch die im feld das glaube ich
nach wie vor eher nicht zu sehr sondern
ich glaube dass die briten einen ganz
anderen weg gegangen sind sie hatten
vier wochen vorher den impfstoff
zugelassen
sie vergeben nur eine dosis an in vielen
fällen und machen die zweite dosis gabe
nicht sie haben vielleicht auch verträge
geschlossen bei denen sie sehr viel mehr
von der haftung übernommen haben das
haben wir ausdrücklich nicht gemacht das
unterstütze ich auch dass die
europäische union das nicht gemacht hat
also da sind schon unterschiedliche
vorgehensweisen gewesen
für mich stellte sich nicht da saß der
klausur in deutschland hat immer gesagt
wenn jemand bei uns nicht haben will wir
neben 100 millionen dosen dem 200
millionen dosen bei uns war erst nicht
so begehrt unter den mitgliedsstaaten
also ich glaube erst genug impfstoff
bestellt worden und zweitens entscheidet
sich jetzt nach der frage wie viele
europäische tage haben wir und was kann
da produziert werden und da sind wir
sehr gut daran dass wir marburg haben
fragt sich ob sich ähnlich würden im
stoff das thema bei den schnelltest auch
wiederholt die auch zum beispiel für uns
zum selbst benutzen immer noch nicht
zugelassen sind in deutschland anders
als in anderen ländern
wenn man sich überlegt südkorea hat im
märz letzten jahres märz letzten jahres
den ersten solcher schnepp test
zugelassen
das heißt auch nicht irgendein land
sondern eine seriöse demokratien high
tech land
und wir haben bis heute solche tests
nicht wirklich weil sich selber machen
kann
wir haben jetzt die ersten anträge auf
zulassung bei unserem hersteller bis
jetzt lang einen antrag gestellt wir
haben sie jetzt schon zugelassen in
österreich zum beispiel wir haben corona
kabinett darüber gesprochen und da war
die frage wollen wir prüfen wie wirksam
sie sind oder lassen wir sie einfach zu
und wir haben uns entschieden alle
gemeinsam wir wollen wissen wie wirksam
sind sie denn wir müssen auch aufpassen
dass diese tests die man selber machen
kann dann nicht zum schluss vielleicht
nur eine wahrscheinlichkeit von 60
prozent haben da wir uns alle nicht
geholfen
es gibt ja längst studien die zeigen
dass auch diese ganz normalen
schnelltest die professionell angewendet
werden dass man die zu hause auch selbst
machen kann dann braucht man sich das
stäbchen weil sie nicht bis oben ins
gehirn was für kinder wenn wir an
schulen decken wirklich keine gute
möglichkeit ist und sicherlich auch dazu
beiträgt dass ein pflegeheim viel
weniger getestet wurde weil es eben auch
unangenehm ist man kann das auch selber
und da wird genauso zuverlässig das
wissen wir jetzt seit herbst oder immer
noch haben wir keine zulassung
nein das stimmt auch so nicht wir haben
eine die hersteller stellen einen antrag
und sie haben einen antrag gestellt
darauf dass es durchaus medizinische
personal durchgeführt werden kann
wir haben den test gemacht also
modellversuche mit lehrern und der
gesundheitsminister jens spahn hat in
der verordnung gesagt alle dürfen das
selber machen die in einer kritischen
infrastruktur oder lehrer und erzieher
sind das heißt dort kann er schnell test
heute selbst angewendet werden entweder
von jemandem der sich ein video
angeguckt hat der erfahrung gesammelt
hat was ich geschultert muss aber kein
keine besondere schulung sein sondern
man kann das mit einem mitgelieferten
video vom hersteller selber machen wenn
man im bereich der kritischen
infrastruktur
das schließt zum beispiel auch
lebensmittelhandel mit 1 will man dort
arbeitet das ist eine dieser game
changer die dann eben doch sehr langsam
in deutschland ankommen sie wurden
gestern im bundestag hier auch
kritisiert zum einen dass der bundestag
so wenig einbezogen wird in diese ganzen
entscheidungen aber auch das von ihnen
so wenig selbstkritik kommt gibt es
einen punkt wo sie sagen das ist etwas
worüber ich mich im nachhinein
ärgere was ich wirklich gerne geändert
hätte und damit meine ich jetzt nicht
die ministerpräsidenten die zögerlich
waren sondern dass sie die kanzlerin
geht das nicht da entscheiden wir schon
gemeinsam
erstens ist es so dass der deutsche
bundestag er den rahmen gesetzt hat für
unser ganzes handeln auch mit den
ministerpräsidenten durch das
infektionsschutzgesetz und zweitens ist
es auch so dass ich gerne über die
ergebnisse berichte die innerhalb dieses
rahmens getroffen werden
aber natürlich ist es auch kein no-go
dass ich irgendwann mal vorher rede
aber man möchte auch gern informiert
werden und ich kenne natürlich auch
viele gedanken aus den fraktionen weil
wir auch öfter miteinander reden und
wenn sie mich fragen was hätte ich
anders gemacht ich habe gestern auf zwei
dinge hingewiesen dass eine ist der
umgang mit den masken die alltags masken
haben uns über die zeit als wir noch
nicht genug medizinische hatten hinweg
geholfen und dabei ich am anfang
zögerlich das hat sich dann gezeigt dass
das wichtig war und das zweite war
darauf bin ich gestern auch eingegangen
dass wir im rückblick natürlich im
herbst zu zögerlich angegangen sind ich
habe damals kein gutes gefühl gehabt
aber ich habe die entscheidung
mitgetragen und deshalb ist es mir jetzt
so wichtig wo wir wieder an dem punkt
sind dass wir in die kontrollierbarkeit
und nachverfolgbarkeit der kontakte
kommen dass wir jetzt richtig handeln
und nicht zu früh zeitig öffnen um dann
zu erleben dass wir wieder hoch gehen in
den zahlen denn wir sehen wie lange man
dann braucht um wieder runterzukommen
das ganze gespräch
[Musik]